era un beneficio para las mujeres
menores de 18 años ahora diferentes
métodos de anticoncepción están
disponibles para muchas más mujeres en
francia y de manera gratuita a partir
del primero de enero los anticonceptivos
son gratuitos para todas las mujeres
menores de 25 años un nuevo paso para
que cada una ejerza control sobre su
cuerpo la nueva medida también cubre los
gastos de una visita al médico así como
las pruebas de diagnóstico
uno de los obstáculos que limitan es el
costo de una visita médica el precio de
los medicamentos y a veces la dificultad
para ir al especialista ahora volver lo
gratuito simplifica las cosas desde el
punto de vista financiero esto en sí
mismo ya no será un obstáculo para la
anticoncepción que da mucha libertad a
las mujeres
la especialista asegura además que el
acceso a anticonceptivos eficaces
también podría reducir el número de
abortos en francia- que llegó a 224 mil
300 en 2018 lo que representa uno de
cada tres nacimientos pero si las
mujeres acogieron con satisfacción la
nueva medida del gobierno también
recuerdan que es una responsabilidad no
compartida con el hombre
en lugar de democratizar esto entre la
población femenina creo que sería mejor
centrarse en la anticoncepción masculina
para compartir mejor esta
responsabilidad que es bastante
engorrosa porque hay muchos efectos
secundarios sobre los anticonceptivos
femeninos especialmente los hormonales
según el inicio cerca de 3 millones de
mujeres jóvenes se beneficiarán de la
nueva medida cuyo costo se estima en 21
millones de euros además se introdujo en
respuesta a una caída en el uso de
anticonceptivos